مستمرين معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه مستجدات
الكارثه الطبيعيه والانسانيه اللي سببها
الزلزال المدمر اللي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا بقوه 7.8 الضحايا الان تجاوزوا
700 قتيل وعشرات الالاف من الجرحى في كل
من البلدين العمليات البحث عن الناجين لا
زالت مستمره وحسبت تصريحات ففي الالاف من
الاشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض والسبب غير
نقص المعدات في سوريا وحجم الدمار الكبير
كمان سوء الاحوال الجويه في تركيا وسوريا
واللي جالس بعرق العمليات البحث وكان
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان طلع وقال
انه الحكومه التركيه تعاقدت مع عدد من
الفنادق في انطاليا علشان يجلسوا فيهم
الناس الناجين والمتضررين من الزلزال واكد
انه راح يتم دفع تعويضات لهم وانه خلال
عام راح يتم اعاده اعمار المناطق المدمره
المعونات هو المساعدات مستمره لسوريا
وتركيا من عدد كبير من الدول العربيه
والاجنبيه هذا غير المنظمات اللي اعلنت عن
دعمها للمتضررين ومطارات تركيا وسوريا ما
وقفت استقبال طائرات بتحمل المساعدات
ومن ساعات اعلى المركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه عن تسيير جسر
جوي وتقديم مساعدات صحيه وايوائيه وغذائيه
لتخفيف اثار الزلزال على المتضررين في
سوريا وتركيا بالاضافه لتنظيم حمله شعبيه
هي الاولى من نوعها لجمع التبرعات
للمتضررين من كلا الشعبين عبر منصات ساهم
وصلت قيمتها ل 13 مليون ريال او 13 مليون
ريال في اقل من 24 ساعه من وقت الاعلان
عنها
هذه الحمله سوف
تشكل برامج متعدده سوف يستفاد من هذه
المبالغ من برامج متعدده وجه بها المقام
الكريم لخادم الحرمين الشريفين وولي عهد
الامين سوف يدشن جسر جوي خلال الساعات
القادمه باذن الله لحمل التبرعات سواء
كانت ايوائيه او صحيه او غذائيه كما سوف
تقوم فرق الانقاذ
بالسفر الى مواقع الحدث
لانقاذ المصابين والمتضررين من هذا
الزلزال وسوف تكون هنالك فرق تدخل سريع
وفرق طوارئ طبيه ذات تدخل سريع وكذلك فرق
تطوعيه من الكوادر السعوديه التي تبرعت
بوقتها وجهدها وخبرتها لتخفيف المصاب الذي
اصاب الاشقاء في سوريا وتركيا كما اننا
سوف نحمل ما نستطيع من مواد ايوائيه وكذلك
غذائيه وصحيه وفقا لما تقوم به فرق
التقييم التي وجه بها خادم الحرمين
الشريفين لتقييم الاحتياج الانساني الذي
يستطيع منها فريق مركز الملك سلمان والفرق
الاخرى لدعم هذه التدخل
ومن وقت ما صار الزلزال الرئيس المدمر
واحنا بنسمع عن مئات الهزات الارتداديه
وحتى زلازل جديده كمان فسمعنا اول يوم عن
زلزال ثاني جنوب تركيا بقوه 7.7 وزلزال
ثالث تركيا بقوه 5.6 واليوم سمعنا عن
زلزال رابع كمان في لواء اسكندرون بقوه
4.5 وطبعا ما يحتاج نشرح قديش اخبار
الزلازل الجديده هذه عامله حاله رعب عند
الناس وقبل دقائق مشاهدينا نقلت وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه اخبار عن توقف عمل منصه
تويتر عبر شركات الاتصالات في تركيا وقيل
انه الحكومه حضرت الموقع او تويتر تحديدا
يعني على خلفيه الانتقادات الموجهه
للحكومه هناك بسبب تعاملها مع كارثه
الزلزال هذه المعلومات بنذكر مشاهدينا ان
وفقا لوكاله لم يتسنى لنا التحقق منها حتى
الان لانه وردت الان ولكن طبعا ستكون من
الاخبار اللي حتكون معانا في الفتره
القادمه يعني
[موسيقى]